[Musique]
il est la cible principale des
contestataires
jean michel blanquer air responsable
pour beaucoup d'une situation devenue
intenable
le poteau pelle c'est la goutte d'eau
mais pourquoi parce que ça met en
lumière une désorganisation totale et
une destruction volontaire de l'école
avec ce mot qui a été utilisé par le
lisons natif est pas contre un virus
c'est d'une violence c'est d'un mépris
scandaleux mag' assez de virus qui le
produisent surtout aimé il manifestait
pas pour contre le virus ait au pouvoir
pendant cinq ans ils ont bloqué notre
pain à dix ils n'ont rien fait ni pour
nos salaires ni pour nos conditions de
travail et maintenant elle maintenant il
vient nous expliquer qu'ils vont doubler
le salaire qu'il moments importants
c'est chacun réussi blanc caire il a à
moitié démolie l'école mais il a réussi
à mettre tout le monde d'accord à
l'école c'est pas mal je pense qu'un
crétin pareil est utile
pour laisser leur chance info laisser
leur chance aux bons à rien les
ministères qui sont gérés par des
techniciens blanc qu'elle n'a jamais été
élu il a jamais été parlementaire et
quand on est élu parlementaire on
apprend la modestie oui on apprend le
contact non je n'appelle pas ça des
missions j'appelle à un changement
profond dans la politique du pays et
l'élection présidentielle est là pour le
faire et donc la question de la
démission à chaque fois c'est pour quoi
faire mais si c'est pour avoir le même
ministre qui dans les trois mois qui
viennent avant la présidentielle mènent
la même politique ça sert à rien deux
minutes plus tard c'est christiane
taubira qui arrive
merci à
tous les jours surtout afin de résumer
le plus
elle avait dit que elle était là pour
essayer de rassembler
si elle est candidate alors qu'elle n'a
pas rassemblé c'est une gagner un tueur
de trop bien sûr je trouverai un dessin
mais vraiment indécent de parler d'autre
chose que de la situation des
enseignantes et des enseignants la
situation des enfants scolarisés
la situation des parents qui
s'inquiètent
[Musique]
les philippot asselineau le pen dupont
aignan ou mélenchon ce pacte
germano-soviétique des voix
parce qu'il a marqué un but à la facem
qui n'a même pas besoin de passe pour
aller à l'assemblée nationale mais moi
on ne demande à mon enfant que
l'habitant qui s'étouffe habite la masse
je suggère une idée pour vacciner les 5
millions qui manquent à l'appel
interdisez le vaccin ils exigeront que
tout le monde se leva s'injecter pour
clore ce chapitre sachez que le sénat a
voté le projet de loi sur le pacs
vaccinale en le réservant aux plus de 18
ans au lieu de 16 ans et sénateurs ont
également supprimé la possibilité pour
les patrons de cafés et restaurants de
procéder à des vérifications d'identité
il a des symboles qu'il faut défendre
coûte que coûte la baguette dimitian
michel edouard leclerc doux pendant
quelques mois un prix de la baguette qui
sera à 29 centimes d'euros donc michel
edouard leclerc fait de la démagogie du
populisme comme il a l'habitude de le
faire c'est un grand classique il vend à
perte il écrase le travail de ses
propres salariés ils méprisent le
travail des boulangers qui se lève à 3h
ou 4h du matin chaque nuit pour défaire
du bon pas comme on a peu de marge c'est
elle c'est ces produits là qui sont à
flatter très vite par par la hausse des
prix donc moi je regrette pas je suis
content de l'avoir fait par contre je
trouve que c'est du cinéma qu'on nous
fait en face qui est sarah knafo
ma collaboratrice
ma compagne il n'y aurait pas eu de
campagne sans s'arrêter à pau